je suis photographe journaliste donc ça
veut dire que j'informe par l'image
mon métier c'est de prendre des photos
qu'ils soient informative donc ça c'est
un sujet que j'ai réalisé en inde sur
une île qui s'appelle ma jolie et qui
est une île qui va disparaître à cause
de la montée des eaux
donc ces gens là vont devenir des
réfugiés climatiques bientôt ces
collégiens vont créer leur journal et
produire textes et photos auparavant
arnaud finistre les invite à regarder
ces images à lui
mieux il leur en explique le contexte et
les incite à en faire une véritable
lecture
mais peut-on encore lire des images
quand on en est littéralement en veille
c'est effectivement une génération ok né
avec la profusion d'imagés ils ont tous
un téléphone portable ils prennent tous
des photos avec leur portable mais
malgré tout quand on s'intéresse un peu
à la question que je leur montre des
images
ils sont capables de me donner des
éléments de compréhension dans cette
image le grand espace occupé par l'eau
est à la mesure de la menace qu'elle
représente
c'est ce qu'a voulu le photographe et
c'est bien en effet ce que les jeunes
ont perçu il passe ensuite à une autre
de ses photos cette photo là elle a été
prise place tahrir au caire pendant la
révolution égyptienne
aller voir ailleurs ce qui se passe et
en ramener des images renault en a bien
saisi l'intérêt de montrer aux gens
qui n'ont pas forcément les moyens d
aller d'envoi
et que nous on peut les présentes
il parlait d'aller en inde il peut aller
en inde parce qu'il peut avoir les
mariam et par certaines personnes ne
peuvent pas y aller comme qu il ramène
des photographies après arnaud finistre
ces collégiens rencontreront également
placide caricaturiste et dessinateur de
presse ce dispositif monte en lien avec
le clemi concerne dix collèges de saône
et loire